manas shir ali docteur en sociologie
politique et spécialiste de l'iran
bonsoir madame shir ali merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france l'iran et
la chine qui vont donc signé un traité
pour 25 ans c'est en réponse aux
sanctions américaines imposées contre
téhéran
c'est en tout cas la république espère
et espère le dirigeant iranien a espère
que les chinois et les russes les
protège contre les américains ça c'est
un espoir d orgue à tous alors on va
voir ce que ça va donner dans par la
suite
en tout cas moi je garde mes doutes
parce que les rapports internationaux
sont beaucoup beaucoup à sifié ne sont
pas du tout de la même façon que les
iraniens des dirigeants iraniens des
voix pour les iraniens c'est quelque
chose de guerre depuis 40 ans ils ont
tapé sur les tambours de guerre
et là il espère que les chinois et par
la suite les russes les soutiennent
contre les américains on va voir ce que
ça va donner mais en tout cas je ne
pense pas que les choses se passent de
cette façon connaissant les rapports
internationaux
alors la serre on parle du du volet
militaire sur le plan économique 400
milliards investis dans l'économie
iranienne l'iran qui en a bien besoin
en tout cas et selon les choses qu'ils
ont qui ont été dites parce que comme
vous le savez très bien entre ces deux
pays tout se passe à huit clos et la
transparence n'a jamais été la
singularité de la diplomatie de terrain
ni de pékin mais en tout cas selon ce
qu'ils nous ont dit jusqu'à là c'est que
la corde évoquent la possibilité d'une
coopération militaire par le biais de
développement de l'armement comme
l'échangé d'informations pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
lutter contre les groupes séparatistes
et contrôler le trafic de drogue
ce n'est pas dans l'économie et vanilla
c'est plutôt dans l'art moment c'est
dans l'économie militaires iraniens
c'est très très dit
vraiment il faut pas mélanger les deux
et cette course finalement à vouloir se
protéger en iran est ce que c'est en
réponse également à l'accord entre les
les deux monarchies du golfe et israël
c'est ce renforcement des relations en
tout cas des pays arabes sunnites avec
israël absolument c'est comme ça que
vous avez décrit c'est par à travers cet
accord la république islamique sous est
de contrer un bras de fer aux américains
en disant que vous êtes en train de
négocier avec les israéliens et avec les
arabes mais nous nous sommes capables de
faire un contrepartie de faire bloc
contre vous grâce aux chinois
et en ce qui concerne justement cette
surenchère de l'armement qui inquiète
washington finalement est-ce que c'est
pas les la faute des états unis d'avoir
voulu isoler l'iran sur sur le plan
international finalement on connaît le
proverbe
les amis de mes amis sont mes ennemis en
tout cas il y à la faute à quelqu'un
c'est d'abord aux dirigeants iraniens
d'avoir mis leur peuple dans la guerre
entre deux blocs de puissance d'un côté
des chinois et des russes
et de l'autre côté les américains ça
c'est la première dès les premières
responsables de cette situation ce sont
les dirigeants italien
il pourrait parfaitement collaboré avec
la planète avec les autres pays du monde
toute relation pacifique et entourant
paix et il n'était pas obligé de
toujours être dans les diplomaties de
deux guerres dans une diplomatie
belliqueuse contre les américains l'iran
n'est pas un pays qui peut tenir compte
tout seul contre les américains
évidemment il a besoin d'avoir des
alliés et donc il est chercher
maintenant ses alliés auprès des chinois
mais la question est de savoir est ce
que les chinois sont de véritables
alliés des iraniens est ce que les
russes par la suite seront des vrais
alliés des iraniens est ce qu'ils vont
soutenir l'iran contre les états unis
alors là dès maintenant je vais vous
dire que la réponse est vraiment loin
détruit non ils ne seront pas de vrais
alliés parce que nous ne vivons pas dans
ce genre d'homme
que les orientaux lors le souhaitent de
créer une guerre entre les deux blocs
il y à des rivalités certainement entre
les puissances du monde il y à des
rivalités qui se traduisent par exemple
dans les pires des cas comme
l'augmentation des taxations sur un
produit ou pour assurer l'ordre et pas
comblé ce ils le souhaitent les arêtes
lors de créer la guerre entre les blocs
de puissance
pas du tout ça ne se passe pas comme ça
et ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on peut
comprendre les relations internationales
vous dites que l'iran à des intentions
belliqueuses et qu'elle veut créer la
guerre entre entre deux blocs l'accord
de vienne pour le coup était le
contraire de cette attitude belliqueuse
ils iront avait accepté en tout cas de
se soumettre à cet accord de vienne qui
a été remis en question par les états
unis mais qui ont continué à enrichir le
rhénium qui a continué à les développer
le programme des missiles
tout ça ce sont les coups de couteau que
l'iran a donné dans le contrat devient
c'est vrai que ce sont les américains
sont sortis mais il faut pas oublier que
l'accord n'était pas pour profondément
respecté par les iraniens
par rapport à ce qu'on nous on n'arrête
pas de nous dire que les iraniens
étaient à 100% fidèles l'accord devient
non la république islamique a continué
son programme des missiles et c'est ça
qui était particulièrement dangereux
aussi bien la région
en même temps pour la paix dans tout le
débat sur la toute la planète
comment est-ce que perçu cet accord en
iran est ce que la population
l'accueille favorablement et au début
exactement au début le soir de la
signature de l'accord
les iraniens étaient très contents parce
qu'il pensait que la république
islamique est en train de se diriger
vers une paix vers des relations
paisibles avec la communauté
internationale et en même temps c'était
quand même une source financière
extrêmement important qui s'est versé
vers l'iran mais par la suite quand les
iraniens ont vu qu'ils n'ont absolument
pas bénéficié de cette ouverture
et que cet argent qui a été débloquée
grâce à obama et que les ans les
oreillettes lors l'ont reçu mais ils
n'ont pas investi dans les projets
économiques à l'intérieur du pays
évidemment on peut comprendre les
iraniens qui se sont tournés contre cet
accord est il le jour où donald trump
est sorti de cet accord il n'était pas
particulièrement triste parce qu'ils
avaient vu que ça n'avait absolument
rien changé dans leur vie quotidien
merci beaucoup mais nasir ali d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france